you know what's [ __ ] up  african people don't like black people  y'all know they treat us like [ __ ]  they talk down to us they think they  better than us  and i don't understand because we're  from the same  tribe kind of  but they like white people though they  treat y'all like family as soon as y'all  come around they get excited excuse me  mr white man  thank you for bringing us here  we love you  yay the white mommy  as soon as they see us they get attitude  hey how you doing  this [ __ ]  we don't like the black man in america  [ __ ] you don't work you don't do  [ __ ]  we don't like you you black [ __ ]  like who are you calling black  [ __ ] i'm brown you midnight who  the [ __ ] are you calling like  like [ __ ] if you stood up against the  building you look like an alley who the  [ __ ]